Like a boss.
I was watching something on that Tesla s and it's like the self driving fucking
car and these two guys computer,
look at guys,
I'll say that because they both had glasses.
So if you have glasses in my world that means you're smart and a lot of people's
world it meets that you know.
But you know I want to be politically correct.
Maybe they will both a couple of fuckheads but anyways,
they were in this car and uh,
they put on the self driving mode and according to the video they put blankets
over themselves and they took a fucking nap.
Okay.
Now Tesla said that there's some alarming youtube videos of people doing shit in
their cars that you're not supposed to be doing,
but they basically took a nap and then somebody wrote in one of the comments
underneath it like,
would you get arrested if you got shit faced,
put it on self driving mode and then sat in the backseat
and you don't make,
you don't know me.
Maybe you're thinking of me,
but I'm always bitching about technology.
I actually am coming around to the self driving car.
Just provided that you could still drive it if you want to.
Um,
cause that is,
that is pretty fucking cool.
Do you realize how fucking on a shape in life,
you know,
how bad like this is going to be for procrastinators?
You know,
the fact that they no longer have to drive themselves to work and they're going
to be trying to finish their fucking presentation in their car.
You know,
you've seen people brushing their teeth or just people literally with an eye
mask on,
just fucking sleeping in the jam jams and then they pull up to work.
You know,
like you set your car alarm and that's like your fucking alarm to wake you up.
Like when it stops and it's in park,
you know,
maybe the horn just goes bad,
bad,
bad.
That'd be too jarring.
They'd be too jarring for people are the future.
Right.
They don't want to fucking deal with anything.
They just want to lay around.
Right.
So they fucking let you lay there in the car.
And I,
you know,
those fucking creepy self vibrating fucking seats.
When you get too close to something,
maybe it does that he just lay in there,
right?
And it just sort of shakes you a little bit and some weird creepy computer
voice.
She can pick the voice too,
right?
Take a right here.
Make that.
Ultimately it's up to you to decide where would you like to go today?
My young friend,
I'm Kinda hungry.
Where would you like to eat?
Sandwich place.
Sure.
That's what you want.
Churches.
Chicken is up on the right.
You don't got no celebrities will jump all over that.
They do the fucking voiceovers to make a little bit of cash because no one pays
for movies anymore.
And they're sick of being in those mighty heroes.
Fucking superhero movies,
one after another.
They're literally out of ideas.
Uh,
I mean once you have like the superhero was fighting each other that they gotta
be nervous in Hollywood just going like,
where do we go from here?
You know,
can we reboot this thing again?
Can we reboot the fucking joker and all that.
But you know what the funny thing is though,
is people will keep showing up.
I guess that makes sense,
right?
God knows they've had the comic books forever and people keep reading those.
You know what?
I'm taking that one back.
I'm wrong about that one again.
Have I been right yet?
Fuck.
Bunch of swings and misses
car.
Mr Car,
excuse me.
Airline is an island,
so how,
oh no,
no,
no.
Stop.
Let me,
that's not good.
Oh No,
no.
Excuse me.
Please.